as all of you know today is my
anniversary I moved to st. Louis six
years ago today and it was about this
time that I I drove past the arch and
eventually I moved into my apartment
which I've already moved out of so for
the six year anniversary and for our
great class mastering the middlegame
we're going to look at one of my
favorite games it's the second most
famous game between burn and Fisher but
it's the best one and also it's the best
burn and since I'm a big Bernie Sanders
fan we're going to feel the burn this
class okay so it's pretty cold in here
so that'll help got to help things up
now as you all know there's the burn
brothers Donald Byrne and Robert Byrne
Donald Byrne died very young and he was
an international master probably Grand
Master strength and he lost a famous
game to Bobby Fischer
when Fischer was 13 years old which was
obviously played in 1956 and this is the
game where Fischer sacrificed his Queen
for at the last count 46 pieces and with
his extra 46 pieces was able to check
made burn who only had a queen now this
is a better game but not as well known
between Robert Byrne the stronger of the
burn brothers not only was he better at
chassis was a better tennis player and
he's white against Robert Fischer in the
US Championship 63 64 as you all know
this was the US Championship that
Fischer won 11 zero and as a result at
the chess club here we always have a 64
thousand dollar prize for anybody who
wins the US Championship with a perfect
score I think as of yet nobody has even
been three-and-oh so they're not going
to go 11 and oh okay and if somebody
does go 11 - no I'm sure Rex will cry a
lot the publicity of 11 - no can't be
worth the money or maybe it is okay so
this is a game played in the u.s.
championship in fact like the US
Championships today there was live
commentary except it wasn't on the
Internet
it was not on television it was you
showed up and you watched and they would
have them whose relayed somehow and the
analysts were worse than they are today
if that's even possible which I guess it
is
okay now Fischer was black and this is
mastering the middle game this middle
game looks pretty boring and Fischer
spices it up by doing something most of
you don't like he intentionally gives
himself an isolated pawn for something
that's more important than pawn
structure if that's even possible and
that is peace activity and you'll see in
this position the pieces aren't very
active okay so again burn is white
Robert Byrne and Bobby Fischer was black
and he plays the Kings in he'd end the
Grunfeld
in fact this position occurred today
although not today for you at home in
the game a co peon versus Geary I'm sure
you've all memorized that game and that
game was a draw and here Fischer played
c6 which is what a Giri played so there
you go now the difference between Robert
Byrne and Akopian is they're both pretty
solid players pretty similar rating to
but a co peon didn't weaken his white
squares this game like Bern did
and when I say weaken the white squares
I mean put all your pawns on black
squares okay so this is still the game
between Akopian and Geary and well here
Byrne played III not something you'll
see a grandmaster do today because now
looks like White's playing checkers and
since this is a chess game that might
not be the right way of playing and
we're severely limiting the power of the
bishop on c1 game now burns playing it
ultra solid and my opinion Robert Byrne
was not good at ultra solid chess burn
was a good attacking player when burn
was
the Sicilian he had a lot of good
attacking victories against other strong
grandmasters this wasn't really his
forte but he's playing a young Fischer
Fischer was known as a tactician and as
a sharp player so maybe he thought since
he was older than Fischer he could
outplay and positionally and the players
develop their pieces nothing too
exciting and the middle game has started
and of course if you asked any grandma
Esther today they would prefer the black
pieces because blacks Bishop has lots of
places to go and White's Bishop is sort
of locked in although if you put this on
an engine it's hard for me to believe
that it would say anything other than
equal because well position is pretty
equal now instead of putting the bishop
on one of these active squares where it
could eventually get traded or attacked
Fischer played b6 because he liked this
diagonal he thought that was a good
place for his bishop okay and burnt
agreed it seemed like bern was trying to
copycat the Meuse Fischer played even
though he was white by basically losing
a tempo by playing III the problem with
this position is sort of funny the way
the game turns out black gets access to
this g3 Square deep and whites position
whereas white doesn't get access to the
d6 Square and there's a couple of
reasons for that and the main one is
pawn on e7 is defending d6 and there's
no pawn defending d3 and when you make a
lot of pawn moves in chess and the pawns
can't move backwards you weaken a lot of
squares and since the C pawn is gone for
both sides and the e2 pawn is moved
there's no defense to d3 which Fischer
takes advantage of so Bishop to a6
pinning the knight bishop a3 again it
looks a little symmetrical and Fischer
plays rook e8 and the reason is this
pawn is pinned Fischer doesn't want to
draw by just trading pieces which is
what happened
Inuk opiate and giri trade trade trade
Akopian was playing for a draw with
white giri made a half-hearted attempt
to win but with all the pieces traded
even though the game went 40 moves it
was pretty equal throughout in fact a KO
pian was in danger of being better but
he didn't want to be better again now in
this game Bern is playing a KO pians
part but not doing as well as a KO pian
again now I want you to get confused
because you already were confused
beforehand I don't confuse you further
I'm not talking to you guys I'm talking
to them at home you guys are a fine
audience okay and I'm not talking about
vara Cobian I'm talking about a co peon
who is actually played for the World
Championship if you can believe that
when Kris moreover if you was a defeated
we're fighting to sprog give him the
left hook right cross okay but at that
time there was a World Championship
between I think was a Leafman and
Akopian okay that's like heaven the US
Championship with like me and Michael
Brooks okay and and Khalifa 'none he was
one of the finest drinkers around he was
one of finest trance players around and
a COPI and lost but he came in second
that's pretty good silver medal okay now
in this game Fischer played rookie eight
for obvious reasons I already stated
Danny why did he play that move doesn't
like Wyatt right and what's his next
move going to be yeah he's playing for a
five and live in the game up okay burn
plays Queen d2 connecting his rooks and
E 5 now it was blacks turn to move and
he wants to get in a space advantage he
could play e4 then his bishop would have
the d3 square and the bishop on g2 would
be blocked for quite a long time you can
also take the pawn on d4 being somewhat
similar to the game now I've noticed the
lower rated you are the more dogmatic
you are because you have little
knowledge
and the one thing that you do know you
said over and over again okay we call
that the Donald Trump syndrome okay
doesn't know very much if you say the
same thing over and over again people
don't hear anything else and they don't
feel the burden
okay terrible okay so in this position
Bern traded pawns and those of you at
home and those of you know audience are
probably wondering what's going on
around here that pawn is pretty weak
okay now the pawn is weak but it
controls e4 so the knight can go to e4
later
and now the knight on e5 much better
than on c6 can now hop into d3 that's a
pretty nice square okay now white has to
be careful because this diagonal is open
and there's a rook there and this
diagonal is not quite as open because
there's a pawn on on d5 so we want to
make sure we don't lose material now a
cursory glance with the very obvious
variation let's take let's make a
blunder because blundering is fun now
what's the winning move for black who
can find it anyone
Bueller sir Knight f3 forking the King
and Queen and if you take the knight you
still lose your queen okay so the light
has to be a little bit careful here
that's one trick and another trick is
this rook is hanging so whoa should be
pretty careful here okay now burn plain
rook F g1 okay now again we stand on the
shoulders of giants and as long as the
Giants don't fall down we should be
pretty safe right you agree that was
like yeah okay and the reason I say we
stand on the shoulders of giants no
Grandmaster would play rook F to D 1 but
since this was 1963 we give him a break
now why did Fisher win this game because
several months before this game Fisher
played a rated tournament game with my
father and he must have learned a lot
from that game that must have been what
happened okay so if you're if you're at
home you can look up the game fisher
feingold 1963 I guarantee that wasn't me
but I have a good excuse wasn't born yet
okay and Smithers excuse to mr. burns is
he wasn't gonna be born for the next 25
years it's a good excuse
okay now the reason a grandmaster today
wouldn't play rook fd1 is it weakens the
kingside black has lots of knights that
can go to f2 also most grandmasters
don't want their rook on the same
diagonal as a bishop
so rook FD won a case of the wrong rook
why did he play it he probably didn't
like his knight being pinned he probably
didn't see the danger and he thought my
knight can go to f4 and I'll have so
many pieces on this d5 pawn that d5 pawn
is finished now that's that could
possibly happen it just didn't happen
this game if you want to see an example
of a recent game where the guy had an
isolated D pawn and he just lost it you
can look at the game Mahmud John Carlson
from round eight of the Qatar Open okay
which was yesterday and in that game
Mahmud yar I've had an isolated pawn and
Magnus Carlsen said thank you
I'll take that pawn and since mama Rob
didn't want to lose in 90 moves down
upon he gave all his pieces away and
resigned okay and Carlson said thank you
again okay then Carlson went to the
Internet and said mama dr was no good
he's my favorite opponent if you have to
win with black mama Gehrig there's your
opponent okay the truth hurts okay so
anyway Fischer played 93 as I alluded to
earlier and Bern was not impressed Bern
thought that night can't do anything and
I still got a lot of pressure on the d5
pawn and burn plague Queen c2 and he
just thought 93 was silly now if we can
go back there's a book on chess called
psychology of chess or in chess bow
chess by a crow Ghia
and as you didn't know Cronus lives in
Boston didn't see that coming and he's
about 400 years old if I'm right I might
have done my math wrong there's actually
a picture on my wall with me and crow
Gaius and about 20 other people okay and
I met him in Moscow in 84
and I never read the book because you
know books probably nonsense but the
important part of the psychology in
chess is figuring out what your
opponent's thinking and either you give
them credit or you don't give them
credit if you know me you won't give me
credit if you go to creditkarma.com
you'll see why okay but Fischer should
have gotten credit because Fischer's
winning the tournament 11 0 he should
get some credit now if my opponent plays
93 and I play the move Queen c2 with an
attack on their night and the night
can't go back to f4 and the night can't
go to b4 and the night can't come in
here
okay there's two possibilities Fischer
is going to move his knight backwards in
which case 93 was a terrible move why
did he do that or he's going to
sacrifice and open up White's King and
that's either good or it's bad Fischer
obviously thought it was good because he
played 93 so when I'm playing a strong
player and they make a move like 93 and
I'm thinking Knight f2 that's no good
well that was their whole plan so
instead of proof pulling the idea I
might say wait a minute
Fischer's about to go 11 0 Fischer in 8
years is going to be timing of in Larsen
6-0 I got to be ready for that
if you can't seat eight years into the
future what good are you okay two days
ago I was telling my friend it's time to
fire Chip Kelly and I just around the
internet one hour ago that he was fired
so he can't see into the future what
good are you
so of course Fischer played Knight takes
f2 might say except choose a good move
it probably wins but the fact that white
allowed it when black had no
other idea was very strange and if I was
white here and I thought Knight f2 is a
good move I may move my knight off of e2
so my queen could take or I might put my
rook back on f1 so my other rook can
come into the middle so Queen c2 pretty
bad move considering the guy was a
candidate although not yet okay
Knight f2 obviously White has to take
yummy yummy and now black plays the
obvious move what is that
Knight g4 check now King f1 is risky
because of Knight check forking
everything notice how I point it to the
bishop first because that was the most
important I was trying to see if you're
paying attention at home okay King f3
that ain't no good King e1 doesn't look
very good
so why PI the obvious move came to g1
okay and black played Knight takes c3
now the reason Byrne allowed this is he
misunderstood the position he was sure
as you are here unless you've seen the
game which you should have that forking
the Queen and rook black was going to
take the rook white would take back and
black would have a rook and two pawns
for two pieces but this pawn looks like
it's going to be lost so materially
speaking it looks very good for white
why it's going to have two pieces for a
ruck and that's why burn went into this
and he probably thought black has
compensation but I have two pieces for a
ruck okay but he didn't understand
Fischer wasn't going for material
equality Fischer was going for a meeting
attack by eliminating all of White's
defenses and when you master the middle
game you'll notice a lot of Grandmaster
games where one side has a lot of pieces
very far from his King and with a
minimal sacrifice you could attack that
King and be successful the game that I
talked about last week which reminds me
of this game is
the game a non shear of which was a
Cambridge Springs where she rod was
black put all his pieces on the
queenside so an on decided to checkmate
a good plan okay you're going to check
wait somebody it would be helpful if two
things occurred your pieces are near the
opponent's king and their pieces are not
defending which is the case here burn
plague Queen d2 and Fisher surprised the
analysts instead of taking the rook he
took the bishop and White's King doesn't
have a lot of defense that has no
defense okay so he took the knight and
black has two pawns for a piece but what
he cares most about are the activity of
his pieces best bishop ever this dish is
probably tied for a second this is a
gray truck and eventually when I say
eventually I mean right now Fischer won
it's open up this diagonal to the king
and this is something that I teach all
of my students buttburn had a good
excuse as you all pointed out I wasn't
born yet so I could have taught him this
also he was much better than me burn
doesn't have a white squared bishop
which means black has the two bishops
black has two bishops white has one
Bishop normally we have a bishop and a
knight for two bishops here White has a
bishop and two knights for two bishops
because black sacrificed a piece and in
this position if I ask you which bishop
is more valuable for black it's this
bishop on white squares because white
doesn't have one of those bishops white
played g3 and III putting all of his
pawns on dark squares and now he has no
white squared Bishop so his white
squares are weak okay
and now Fischer played a brilliant move
opening up the diagonal d4 not only
threatening a piece but man this is
looking sort of scary now although
losing a piece is also scary okay so
burn took this [ __ ] b7 check man this is
looking tough we only have one pawn for
a piece but black has the
best pieces ever okay and I'm not very
impressed with these two pieces not
impressed at all and these pieces are
just waiting to be captured okay now
obviously if your pieces are going to be
captured that's bad and if your pieces
are bad that's also bad but there's more
bad there's a lot of bad going on here
this King on g2 that's bad there's just
no defense to this okay now if we want
to not get Chuck mated we could give all
of our pieces away also a good choice
we could play Knight f3 and then after
Queen takes Queen Bishop takes Knight
materials equal and White has two rooks
hanging and a knight pinned so this
would be reasonable so you can't play
Knight f3 you can't block with this
Knight
we're going to have to move the King
okay movie the King is tough because
there's a lot of tricks now in the game
burn play King f1 but let me show you
sort of a basic trick which actually
I've used a couple of times in my chest
career let's play King g1 okay now if we
go check you'll notice this rook has
over worked the rooks defending the
Queen and the rooks defending the back
rank so we could play rook e1 check if
rook takes rook we get a queen plus a
knight for good measure
Plus checkmate probably if we don't take
the rook we could win simply by just
being up material and black is up an
exchange in a pond
okay so King g1 doesn't work for law
simple tactics for these guys okay
King h3 may you couldn't pay me to play
King h3 I'm not I can't I can't make
moves like that okay then you're just
asking to get checkmated the black rook
can go to h5 the black queen you go to
d7 I'm not putting my king on h3 okay so
you play King f1 that makes sense okay
now of course we would like to get our
Queen in here somewhere
that would be a good idea okay Queen d5
is impossible because of the knight on
c3
so Fischer played Queen d7 this is a
very famous present position in chess
history okay because sort of like the
grandmasters here we do commentary on
the US Championship the US Women's
Championship the US Junior Championship
and the Sinquefield Cup and usually I do
all four and then I make mistake after
mistake
I suggest moves like Queen h6 and my
partner's like Bishop takes Queen I'm
like oh yeah
didn't see that Bishop there then I
suggest Queen b5 check and my partner's
like both Knights can take it I'm like
oh yeah okay
but the grim masters on hand who was
commentating on the position they didn't
blunder pieces and their suggestions
they had a misunderstanding of the
position the grandmasters on hand they
said well Black has one pawn for a piece
and there's not really a big threat so
black is winning and they were very
surprised when white resigned here so
the grandmasters thought black doesn't
have enough compensation for a piece and
white gave up now that's compensation
for a piece okay well what has a lot of
threats Rick aides he hates a nice move
and Queen h3 is a nice move and well
there's all kinds of fun stuff okay so
according to Fisher I don't know if it's
true he was very upset his opponent
resigned because he was looking forward
to brilliant checkmates the the best
variation to show you what a great
attack Black has is Queen f2 Queen h3
check King g1 this looks like White's
King is pretty safe but now we have a
double overwork we get overtime we got
this Queen and this rook are both
defending e1 and they're both defending
d4 and the Queen is stopping Queen G to
mate
okay Queens you to mate is a good move
except it's not me because the white
queen is here okay so black has the
brilliant winning move rook to e1 check
obviously Queen takes rook hangs mate in
one
and if rook takes rock this should take
is D for the immediate threat is Queen G
to mate that's a good move this ship
takes Queen is also a good move and
after Bishop takes Knight which is
ridiculous white still lost then even
after the worst to move White's lost and
why can't do anything here white has to
give all his pieces away a computer
would defend by something I don't know
how though it's hard I guess 94
yeah 94 you won't get mated you just
lose your queen yeah see I just felt
like a computer probably rookie 4 - wow
talk about losing all your pieces ok so
that was one variation that both players
saw but it's very hard to do anything
because this rook e1 is in the air so
for example if I play some random legal
move there should be two we just do the
same thing
okay this should takes night check wins
immediately because of this Queen g2
mate so at least Queen f2 made the rook
defend the night rather than the Queen
defend both Queen d7 with the very
simple threat of Queen h3 and somehow if
white could stop Queen h3 which you
can't a tricky G it looks pretty good
yeah okay and this is like the best
possible pieces you could have that's
really active pawn structure doesn't
matter number of pieces don't matter
what matters is King safety and peace
activity blacks down a piece look at
White's pieces they're all hanging or
terrible and blacks pieces are the best
okay and that's how crisscross got their
name and they're the worst so that's the
way life is sometimes so after Queen d7
if you have an engine at home it'll tell
you black has a monster winning
advantage but the Grandmaster is on site
thought white was doing great because
White's up a piece but they didn't see
all of blacks threats and they really
misunderstood the position when you have
a bishop like this and your opponent has
no pawns there and their King is wide
open there's just no chance if we could
give white a bishop here and put a pawn
on f2 but the King on g1
that's okay but with nothing around the
king there's simply no defense and that
was in my opinion Fisher's better game
with Byrne because other grandmasters on
site thought he was losing when his
opponent resigned the Queen sacrifice he
played against Donald Byrne which was
brilliant because Fischer was 13 years
old
a few was after the Queen sacrifice
Donald Byrne was playing on for no
reason just down several pieces so this
was an amazing game and well it was one
of the games Fischer played to go 11 Oh
in the US Championship he wasn't winning
all of the games easily like like this
one but it just shows you even in a
symmetrical position symmetrical looking
one of the best players of the country a
candidate lost in 22 moves with white
because black had more active pieces
black changed the pawn structure black
had more active bishops and most
importantly taking the bishop on g2
instead of am easily exchange was very
important because this bishop had no
equal had no counterpart that's very
important when you have the two bishops
you find which one of your bishops
the other guy doesn't have and that's
the squares you can invade on they have
no defense in this particular position
the other bishop is also quite good
because this bishop is very silly on a3
and when Fischer realized his bishop
wasn't doing everything on a6 he just
put it back on b7 where it's obviously
better and Fischer just his opponent
Byrne couldn't do that his Bishop on
beech who really didn't do anything
anyway except defend and that's pretty
funny in the final position all of
whites pieces on the diagonal are in a
lot of danger but that's not why he
resigned he resigned because of the
terrible King safety well I hope you
like that mastering the middle game the
lecture was a little too long
but I'll make it a little shorter next
time
Oh